everyone is so serious now
i went out to dinner tonight
in a parking lot surrounded by
traffic cones thanks gavin newsom
because we can't
walk in a building unless we promise to
burn it down blm
so we have to sit in a parking lot
surrounded by traffic let's have dinner
and and this we're we're we're in echo
park los angeles
which is a nightmare it's uh a rapidly
decaying hellscape and it's full of
these
artists and pseudo-intellectuals but
primarily dilettantes
people that think they're in the arts
and are not people are under the
impression they are comedians
and are not uh and then of course you
get a
few comedians here and there uh we're
sitting in an end this restaurant called
tex which is a horrible name but it's a
good restaurant it's
it's country french as the waitress uh
told us she has not showered in weeks
and she has her
ratty hair uh clinging to her face
uh in amphetamine sweat and she said
it's country french
cuisine she is correct about that and
the food is very good the food is very
good
but text tax what's it called test
who cares folks it's gone anyway
it yeah t-a-i-x
french restaurant and it's really good
it's been there since 1927.
well what's coming in a high-rise in
echo park
because more uh people need to live
in condos in echo park so they have a
high rise coming in and this restaurant
is closing
we all know that we all know that
and instead of just enjoying one of our
last meals of course we have the
waitress
who we have to relive her uh
horror for the entirety of the meal
she's telling us about the owner and if
the owner's not really doing anything
and the owner doesn't let them know
what's going on and they don't know when
they're closing and they
he didn't you know she goes well
we had to set this whole thing up we had
to get the tables and chairs from the
downstairs
and then she's talking about the
councilwoman i hope uh
nithya wins because some some socialist
candidates she goes i hope nythia wins
you know she's taking deep breaths and
and i want to grab her and say
with all due respect can you shut your
mouth please
we are trying to enjoy a meal can you
shut your mouth every time she came near
the table
i mean she looked wounded i'm like do we
have to take you to a hospital
i know it's been a tough five months i
know you haven't worked can you pull it
together for christ
i can't deal with it shut up about the
city councilwoman
who you think is going to save your life
i hope she win
i hope she wins this gaunt heroin addict
at the french restaurant and this is all
the servers now
all of the syrup because now it's the
fall and i'm doing a lot of
you know one of my sports which i go out
to dinner now and this is kind of my
sport we kind of settle into the
from now until january this is going out
to dinner season you see people
you haven't seen in a while and now
because i live in los angeles you get to
go out to dinner and parking lots and
alleys and things like that and it's
great but the servers now
are like they're they have this
weird like they're wearing their heart
on their sleeve because they've been
out of work for so long and everything's
been so tragic for
so long and they feel like
you have to sit there and like
take it you have to like stomach
their nightmare of a life while you try
to eat
you know risotto and you have to sit
there and go
yes the owners doesn't he doesn't even
tell you when it's closing huh
what do you want from us you want to
come live with us is that what you
envision happens at the end of this
i go well why don't you live with us
this seems fair
don't tell me that you hope a certain
politician won during dinner
who cares leave it alone
it's potentially a volatile conversation
because i hope i hope she won
i hope she won i'm sleeping in this lot
god i'm trying to eat food
that's a little expensive and i don't
want to feel guilty about it
so can you get out of here i mean the
woman had the look of somebody who like
chases down semen with cough syrup under
a bridge
without like the spunky fun-loving
personality you'd imagine
someone like that having i don't want a
super serious in the midst of a crisis
server put it together i just did a big
election livestream with rogan i was
tired
the airbnb canceled on us i didn't get
any sleep the night before
i got in an argument with dan the kid
that opens for me and i we i made him
go sit under a tree i'm like i don't
want to look at you i we can't even be
in the same parking lot
we get to rogan's early nobody's there
we got to sit on the curb
because the airbnb couldn't get a
cleaning crew in the day is a nightmare
you know what i did i went to work i
shut my mouth and went to work and we
had a great time
i didn't uh make everybody uh you know
is participate in in my misfortune
it's not fair keep it
close to the vest